nein
wir mussten durch meine lieben freunde
und herzlich willkommen zu einer weit
bringen
ich mach das mal eben ganz schnell aus
hier jetzt müsste eigentlich bewegen
jeden moment sich in wunderschönes
wetter verwandeln you nehme meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft facts heute am
dienstag sogar passend diesmal ihr habt
mir wieder fleißig facts per mail an
kontrast gmail.com geschrieben ich kann
es immer noch sagen da kommt zurzeit
richtig richtig viele gute sachen an
konkreter gmail.com mit effekt schreiben
die ihr noch nicht irgendwo gesehen habt
sondern selbst ihnen die rausgefunden
habt oder so das wäre super geil
es kam wieder richtig geil effekt an zum
beispiel wird sagen wir fangen direkt an
und zwar erste fake kommt von dem user
stöppel das ist ein super namen er heißt
eigentlich alles aber stöckl ist sein
spitzname und die soll den stoppeln also
ist ein cooler fällt mir zugesendet und
zwar sehen wir schon so eine
wunderschöne kiste da sind so ein paar
items drin ich nehme jetzt einfach mal
raus
ich hab natürlich eine rosa glasscheibe
genommen weil ihr wisst heute auf meine
lieblingsfarbe
und jetzt gibt's ja zehn millionen
facebook - wo ist meine lieblingsfarbe
steht ja egal
lasst es sein nein ich möchte so
jedenfalls ihr seht ihr schon ich habe
hier seine schwarze glasscheibe hier so
eine durchsichtige also ich alle sind
durchsichtig mehr oder weniger die
restaurants und das sind ja immer so
diese hit boxen das was da so drin ist
das sind ja diese boxen diese blöcke und
wenn ich hier drin kann ich ja
eigentlich nix setzen das ist genauso
wie wenn ich hier auf einem block stehe
und direkt an darunter bin und da kann
ich ja nix setzen oder wenn ich hier
direkt vor dem block stehe kann ich ja
auch nicht selbst da kann ich keinen
bock sitzen weil ich ja daneben stehe
dann wäre der blog ja quasi in mir drin
allerdings ist es bei diesen
glasscheiben so dass diese hit boxen da
ich weiß nicht ob's verpackt ist oder ob
es extra kann es eigentlich nicht sein
dass ich spiele es gab im latest schnitt
der snapshot also hat microsoft noch
nicht mehr heraus gefallen
wahrscheinlich ich kann hier einfach mal
eine glasscheibe setzen und eventuell
auch ein tnt und jetzt kann ich aber
nichts mehr setzen also wenn ich quasi
hier in dieser hit box hinten drin
stehen das geht nicht irgendwie sondern
da steht in dieser es gibt nur in dieser
hit box wenn ich da so eine ecke setzte
kann ich quasi dadurch sachen hier daran
setzen das ist so als würde ich hier und
hier einfach so etwas hin setzt deswegen
habe ich noch ein paar verschiedene
blöcke gegeben das ganze kann ich auch
mit matt ruhe machen kann ich einfach
daran setzen
und wenn ich jetzt hier rechts liegt
darauf mache kann ich hier da jetzt von
cobblestone einfach hinsetzen mehr geht
hier nicht also ich kann da nicht noch
irgendwie daneben einsetzen
aber diese boxen sind irgendwie ein
bisschen verpackt beziehungsweise ihr
könnt es solange ausnutzen
wie es halt noch da drin ist das ganze
funktioniert egal bei welchem glas egal
mit welchen blocken ich kann das ja auch
mit glas machen und nach kiste oder ich
kann mir hier zum beispiel in quarz
block neben den daran setzen die dann
einfach mal noch so ein cobblestone das
geht mit allen möglichen sachen also
diese hit boxen sind echt total crazy
irgendwie noch und da muss man kräfte
auf jeden fall noch was verändert anke
ein stapel für diesen coolen freunde
bevor wir weitermachen mit dem nächsten
feld möchte ich euch ganz kurz noch
etwas sagen und zwar damals mal damit
angefangen dass ich so geräusche immer
erwähnt habe in den folgen tier konnte
mir die kommentare schreiben was ihr
denkt was das für ein geräusch sei das
letzte geräusch war übrigens übrigens
das klicken von einem kugelschreiber das
wurde von lorena b punkt erkannt als
erstes und
ich möchte nur sagen dass in dieser
folge irgendwann tritt in dieser folge
ein geräusch auf das werde ich rein
schneiden und da könnt ihr mir in die
kommentare schreiben was das ist so oft
wie ihr wollt könnt ihr das in die
kommentare spam und dann ist euer
kommentar eventuell im nächsten video
bzw wird euer name dann erwähnt wenn ihr
der erste seite ziehen sie die ärzte die
das gerät also hört gut hin und schaut
euch das video auf jeden fall zu ändern
vielleicht kommt ganz am ende ich weiß
ja nicht viel spaß auf jeden fall
weiterhin beim video so ich würde sagen
wir machen direkt weiter mit dem zweiten
effekt und zwar seht ihr schon da war
doch vorhin zweites netter portal ja ich
hab den effekt allerdings noch mal
ausprobiert und irgendwie funktioniert
er doch nicht im neuesten snapshot
deswegen will ich euch noch gar nichts
böses jetzt irgendeinen kopf setzen
irgendwas total falsch ist sondern wir
machen weiter mit den anderen krieg den
wir von gesundheit mit einem andern
fekter mir von ben zu gesendet wurde und
zwar meint elisabeth dass ich habe ja
einmal ein video gemacht minecraft wo
ich euch gezeigt wie man unter wasser
atmen kann mit hilfe einer tür
aber ihr habt altholz dabei dann würde
ich mir ganz schnell crafting table
machen und in crafting table schnelle
wurden dort weil die könnt ihr einfach
hinsetzen und hinter dieser wurden dort
ist dann ein bereich wo quasi kein
wasser durchkommt also auch wenn ihr die
tür aufmacht ist in diesem bereich wenn
ich eine tür setzte hinter dieser tür
beziehungsweise wenn ich die tür
aufmache ist hier komplett halt free
also ich kann hier arten und heute zeige
ich euch wie ihr unter wasser atmen
könnt mit bambus an kräften und zwar
erkennt es ich gehe jetzt einfach mal
ganz kurz in den game mode 0 das heißt
ich bin jetzt sterblich und ihr sieht
okay ich bin unter wasser und über mir
ist eine glasschicht und ich komme da
nicht raus und alles mögliche und
richtig doof alles dann könnt ihr kein
zuckerrohr direkt darauf setzen weil ich
gehe mal ganz kurz und atmen wieder ganz
kurz damit ich hier nicht direkt
verrecke weil das so ist war hier
überall von wasser umgeben allerdings
muss der blog auf denen diese zuckerrohr
steht muss von wasser umgeben sein das
heißt maximal 1
sand weg das heißt hier setzt quasi
wasser hier könnt ihr zuckerrohr
draufsetzen kann hier rein und kann hier
drin atmen so ich kann jetzt ja auch
einfach wieder hoch schwimmen und so und
das ist jetzt quasi meine art im station
dingsbums als wenn ihr uns euch in
unterwasser haus bauen wollte vielleicht
sieht cooler aus wenn ihr das mit zucker
macht und nicht mit irgendwie türen oder
so damit ihr atmen kann das wäre
vielleicht ganz cool zum erdboden
wenn ich jetzt allerdings den sand blog
hier wieder hinsetzen wächst dass hier
noch ein also es wächst nicht mehr aber
steht hier noch ein bisschen nacherzählt
wird halt wirklich einfach weggehen
das ist genauso wie wenn ihr damals war
es ja so dass wenn man so gras so
gemacht hat dass man das jetzt auch
machen kann also mit so einer hackl da
drüber im sommer mit seiner hoch und
wenn man dann das wasser einfach
weggenommen hat dann ist es nach derzeit
verfügt ich glaube mittlerweile verfügt
das nicht mehr da wächst langsamer aber
das hier bleibt jetzt auf jeden fall
hier stehen wird sich jetzt auch gleich
einfach disbon weil es halt wirklich
hier unten nicht mit wasser umgeben ist
also die sache ist wenn ihr unter wasser
seit und ihr wollt atmen dann nimmt am
besten zuckerrohr weil das ist
vielleicht dazu kriegen nimmt am
liebsten immer zuckerrohr weil das könnt
ihr quasi einfach wenn ihr könnt ihr
könnt auch hier ein blog hinsetzen könnt
ihr das sogar drauf machen
am besten hat immer zwei war der mai
krankheit auch zwei hoch ist und guck
mal jetzt bin ich hier allgemein schon
über wasser und das nein damit kann man
schon coole sachen machen eigentlich
kommen wir nun zur effekte mir von
mugabe zu gesendet wurde und zwar kann
ich mit einem pferd wieder in den never
noch ins entgehen also das pferd kann
quasi nur in dieser realen welt hier
existieren ich mache das ja mal ganz
kurz ab kann jetzt weg laufen wie man
immer so eine scheiße line up machte
nochmal eine alter ok blitz ist die
abdrücke gut fährt ihn kurz mit hier
wird man ganz gut hier in etwa kann
sie versuchen sich mal zwangsrabatt
tschuldigung sowie könnte nämlich
endeavour gehen wir stehen jetzt hier
drinnen das ist jetzt ein bisschen kacke
auch wenn ich jetzt mal fünf drücke ihr
seht das ist der aber komisch ich gehe
jetzt mal hier raus mit dem pferd so ist
das noch mal ganz gut zu sehen
ich gehe hier rein und dann wird diese
dieses portal geht wirklich für das
pferd als block anerkannt also ich stehe
quasi hier drin ihr lädt das sind alles
blöcke ich kann die gegen schlagen und
es wird kaputt gehen das pferdchen kann
einfach nicht mitkommen dort steht dann
quasi in dem portal drin ich hab das
jetzt einfach mal ausgemacht wegen
diesen scheiß geräusch entsteht quasi in
dem portal drin genau das gleiche smid
nennt portal da wird halt wirklich
einfach durchfallen es steht quasi
einfach da drinnen es kann nicht mit in
etwa das ist halt ich finde es ein
bisschen traurig weil warum sollte man
selbst teleportiert werden können aber
werde nicht das ist das wäre richtig
cool wenn man mit zum pferd wirklich
dich durch sam reiten können die ganzen
namens kaputte länder mehr kaputt boxen
können und so das ventil für richtig
cool dann kann nur mit für den fake
danke an jerry hd für den nächsten akt
und zwar habe ich euch ja in den letzten
26 folgen also was mit tnt in
kombination mit wasser und das ist dann
kein schaden macht aber es macht zwar
schade aber es macht keine
zerstörungskraft und so was alles also
es hat keine zerstörungskraft man meinen
deutsches so früh am morgen so kaffee
wie das wissen ich schreib gleich sowie
abitur und beziehungsweise morgen und
deswegen ist mein ganzes ziehen voll mit
irgendwelchen wirtschaftssachen wünscht
mir also viel glück in den kommentaren
ja jedenfalls ich habe hier drei tolle
items drin und zwar tnt sand und ein
feuerzeug und so zeige ich euch jetzt in
dem ich meine welt kaputt mache wie tnt
unter wasser doch schaden machen kann
zwar setzten wir ein tnt dorthin
platzieren einen sand darauf zünden das
ganze an das dnt wagt sich über das über
den sand
jetzt schon
es ist halt wirklich einfach kaputt
gegangen unter wasser an erinnerung noch
mal wenn ich hier jetzt einfach einen
tnt hinsetzen würde man dies jetzt mal
einfach entzünden und sonne das an das
ganze wird gar keinen schaden machen ich
würde zwar weggedrückt werden
aber es macht halt kein schaden wenn ihr
da ganz allerdings einen moment wenn ihr
da allerdings ein war ströme einen
draufsetzt wagt sich das team gegen die
über den sand und ihr seht schon traurig
auch hier sind ach so wir sind gewiss
auf dem bett bewegen hatten die
zuschauer gar nicht so gesehen ist
kaputt ein bisschen traurig dass ihr das
jetzt wisst bzw sich auch und zwar wenn
ihr jetzt die unterwasser basis von
eurem kumpel kaputt machen wollt dann
holt euch einfach ein bisschen zucker
satzes ins wasser atmen erst mal ein
bisschen baut das ganze auf und dann
könnt ihr das ganze auch unter wasser
mit tnt kaputt bomben und na ja ich
würde sagen meine lieben freunde das
war's mit der heutigen folge minecraft
fans euch gefallen hat will ich mich
definitiv über einen mag ich freuen das
zeigt mir immer ja komm wir feiern die
serie macht die bitte weiter schaffen
wir ja irgendwie ich weiß nicht schaffen
wir 2000 dass wir auf jeden fall so
einzahler will ich mir denken was läuft
bei euch schaffen wir das dann drückt er
den like button nach oben ich hoffe ihr
habt das versteckte geräusche in diesem
video erkannt wenn ja schreibt mir in
die kommentare und eventueller
kommentaren im nächsten mal erwähnt und
sonstwie sagen fakes p konto per fax an
fachkräfte gmail.com und